[Música]
oi meu nome é rodrigo e tem 10 anos e do
5º ano
hoje vou falar pra vocês como a
reciclagem pode virar arte
o luxo do lixo você já pensou o que você
pode fazer com seu lixo reciclável
tem-se bem você pode fazer arte sem
limites e você quer fazer parte da
experiência em si rápido e aceite o
convite porque isso pode ajudar o mundo
e deixar o mais bonito
minha parte dessa história reciclagem
earth é uma conexão que sempre esteve
presente na minha vida
a reciclagem a tia uma conexão que
sempre presente na minha vida eu sempre
usei o conceito da reciclagem por
intuição pois sempre adorei a usar os
materiais transformar os materializados
em novos produtos que a criatividade é
uma nova do meio
sempre adorei recicláveis e criar novas
coisas sempre adorei em inventar
histórias e brincadeiras
a minha vida é marketing eu só queria te
kerbel a circundam de transformar
recchia e ressignificar fique atenta
acertou seu dom da vocação ele diz muito
sobre você mesmo muito pequena e viaje
em tudo que podia
já fiz vários trabalhos trabalha com
esse tema e pretende fazer mais um vídeo
de uma referência do projeto realizado
em realizamos uma experiência que elas
batman
[Música]
eu adorei fazer parte desse trabalho e
aqui vocês podem ver ao vivo e você
ficou interessado
mas como faz etapas do projeto etapa o
definir locais de aplicação do projeto
você pode aplicar em escolas empresas
parques museus conjuntos habitacionais
condomínios e comunidades
etapa 2 dia do lixo reciclável
a comunidade vai selecionar o lixo é que
disse pode virar arte
3 o lixo será preparado para virar arte
para isso
lavar tirando os resíduos e já os e
deixá los prontos para comercialização
que assim quiserem etapa 4 definir
porque será que atua na tela um desenho
específico ou desenho abstrato etapa
simples colágeno lixo na tela proposta e
até mais 3 finalização com cores na tela
podendo correr com os 3 volts em razão
do projeto é aumentar a utilização do
lixo reciclável no brasil em são paulo
[Música]
no brasil são produzidas várias
toneladas de lixo por dia 250 mil
toneladas por dia em são paulo de 9 mil
toneladas de co2 menos de 10% são
recicladas
agora vou dizer pra vocês uma composição
do leite brasileiro sabia que 2% e 2% é
de vidro
os outros dois por cento é de metal como
ferro e aço 3% plástico 26% papelão 52%
lixo orgânico e 15% outros dados
curiosos para uma comparação na alemanha
63 por cento do lixo é reciclado e o
país número 1 do mundo que mais recicla
bank brasil diversas assim não é bom
também da de outros dados curiosos são
que 97 das latinhas de alumínio são
recicladas e 55% das garrafas pets
também são reciclados
também dois criar uma referência na cena
coletiva com significado a partir da
experiência da arte promover uma
experiência interessante do coletivo
dentro de uma comunidade estimular a
criatividade a partir do lixo reciclável
3 promover conscientização é estimular
que cada pessoa tenha consciência de
como é importante de como é importante
separar os materiais antes do descarte
pois só assim a reciclagem pode
transformar pode começar e também da
inspirações as pessoas a fazerem mais
arte
bom essa é uma idéia do impacto nas
pessoas
você quer mudar o mundo começa muito
começa a criar começa a mudar os seus
espaços
faça você mesmo universo mais bonito
aspecto intelectual por ele despertar o
interesse pela arte pelo social
respeitar a autoestima o sentido
coletivo interessa experiência são as
palavras de ordem
bom agora falar sobre as minhas
inspirações que ele seria seu é do vik
muniz
ele faz várias áreas com lixo reciclável
e já fez também acho colchão colatina
açúcar manteiga de amendoim e geléia
outra inspiração é de agility a
exposição cristiano é bom de longe
parece uma imagem normal não é
mas se a gente ver bem de pertinho é uma
imagem só de latinhas que a gente bebe
refrigerante sucos e cervejas realizou
106 mil latinhas de alumínio que a mesma
quantidade de lixo que é jogar nos
estados unidos que a chegada em 30
segundos que você ficou esperada começa
aqui a eu já criei minha árvore e serve
e espero que vai querer raízes
agora sua vez obrigada
[Aplausos]